what good evening everybody thank you
for coming along this evening I shall
start by reading the emergency
evacuation Hamilton please note that
this meeting will be audio recorded
please prognostics turn off any my wife
and I put my side should we be required
to evacuate the building that you please
leave the room by the door to the fire
escape staircase please hold both
handrails in places very wet or slippery
if anyone is unable to use the stairs
when they please allow others to exit
the room before they go to the fire
escape door where they can then be given
assistance our assembly point will be in
a public car park at the side of the
Civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not be turned to the building
until given permission to do so I can't
resolve item number one of the agenda
apologies for absence we have apologies
from counselor mr. and mrs. Mason and
councillor McPherson substitute members
we welcome councilor eaves for Council
mr. Mason and counselor mrs. Foy former
councillor mrs. Mason not members
attending councilor Smith
and item number forward two minutes of
the meeting held on the 9th of October
2018 members of those minutes circulated
to them there's one very minor addition
it's just we need to point out it was
stated the telephone list had been sent
out to members prior to the event that
wasn't quite true and the telephone just
went out on the 19th of October my
apologies for making that statement I
thought it had been sitting on them
there's a road it was sent by the deputy
leader looks like a publish them by the
number five declarations of interest
including any whipping decorations I to
number 6 which is the council's use of
social media and the council's
communication process this item has been
circulated to them and this is basically
an update from the well I think the
report is relatively short hopefully
explanatory but it might be worth just
providing some additional information in
terms of the latest statistics on things
that have been happening in relation to
the the various social media platforms
if that of the community does he survive
the report do you want to just go
through those yeah
if we just go through there's just some
figures everything in there show usually
to the committee that's absolute farmers
any extra information
we welcome that it is any questions of
these okay and so we've got the latest
social media stats Facebook's we
Facebook sorry we have 2166 followers
which is increasing post engagements so
that's where people who look at the post
share it send it on we have had so far
8320 for our highest reaching posts are
those involve videos so that is
something which the communications team
are looking to do a lot more or and our
highest people reach it reached the
number of twenty two thousand nine
hundred and eleven
rahman the 31st of october to the 6th of
november we've had 156 comments posts
and 221 shares the most popular topics
at the moment are the hockey woods
playgrounds being reopens we had a lot
of engagement we had a reach of 13,000
and the tummy silhouettes that are
touring the district so far that's how
to reach of 11,000 and it's been our
best performing social media purposes so
far we have just published a video to
promote weddings at the old house where
we actually interviewed the first
and that has already had a reach of
4,000 over 4,000 that's only being out
for about a week so we envisage as we do
more promotion of that social media and
use platforms like Instagram we should
be able to though those things will
definitely increase and with regards to
Twitter we now have four thousand five
hundred and fifty four followers our
numbers are increasing we have since our
last meeting we have introduced a
morning greeting which is something that
county in Essex County highways have
been doing for a while and we have had
quite a lot of engagements through that
I know that customer services have had
some benefits of people being able to
contact us via social media rather than
all going through the phones now and I
think because we do this opening
greeting in the morning it encourages
people to come via this platform if they
want to contact our members can you just
explain very briefly what that greeting
is good morning we're here all day on
Twitter to answer your questions and
queries if there's something nation'
going on we will and possibly relate to
that factor on about fireworks guide
walks which got loads and loads of
shares and retweets so they're the types
of things that we like from we've also
we promote things that going on in the
district you know if it's Tuesday we'll
say remember it's market day today
Rochford to go down there the same for a
li and obviously with the tawny
silhouettes we've been we've been
pushing those as well and it has proved
quite successful we have had forty six
thousand tweets impressions so
basically that means that our tweets
have been shared and liked and commented
on and shared on as well so we're very
pleased with how suddenly how Twitter is
progressing it was one of the platforms
that we knew we had to do some work on
and we definitely seen the the rewards
for that top tweets recently has been a
video produced by the RSPB which was
about what is he Ireland and Thursday I
believe I'm going to Southend Airport
where they're having a remembrance event
there and we're going to try and
Facebook that live so again when we
don't place but overall we've had a
really really good idea but this is
going to be much more visual than
anything we've ever done before so it
goes it goes okay but we're expecting
and with regards to Gulf delivery but
it's not a social media platform we
obviously use social media gov
deliveries are soryong tell me more
alert it's how we communicate with
residents customers businesses our
subscriptions even after GDP are
steadily rising obviously had we had a
big exercise where we had to go through
the whole database and identifying
people that hadn't used the system and a
decision was made that we need people
and asked them if they want to subscribe
which is not what all councils have done
but we thought we would go right back to
basics with that and say our numbers
held and are going up so
please well our unique subscribers so by
unique subscribers that is per email
address
obviously per email address you can
subscribe to many topics but just
looking at email address registers we've
got nine thousand two hundred and five
subscribers which is about what the
company got delivery would expect from a
variety of our size based on our
population so yes we're quite weary you
know that that's going really well I
think the last meeting is where we
discussed using a social media platform
called muster point that basically takes
our Instagram on Twitter Facebook and on
one platform so that we can we can
assign things that come in and get
customer services involved has been
approved and training is being arranged
at the moment very quickly as well
Instagram this is something really
pushing we've got 128 followers our
largest demographic is 25 to 34 year
olds which is 42 percent we know that
this is a platform that is used a lot by
young people so we are hoping to work
with the Youth Council to you know see
what walk and get some advice from them
people would like to see from us on this
this account and again the most popular
items so far have been the tummy
silhouettes they've shared and followed
by local other local authorities as well
so Instagram is growing I think it was
handy to have the statistics I think the
members and consider the initial pre
meet in that it will be happy to have
those obviously for the council to use
as a foundation and a comparison in six
years time councillor Lucas cool thank
you so much is your anybody that we can
be or able to dispose of designs and
satellite that could be put on these
various forms of communications you know
assembly make something up would you
give Robert real or can it be got rid of
I think that what we try and do through
the various mediums is is react to
information that's put on social media
but responding directly to individual
questions can be problematic I think and
you know one has to be difficult about
getting into you know spotting something
on on a on a Facebook page and then
instantly benefiting something you know
to try and correct the situation my
experience and believe what they see on
on Facebook so you know if someone posts
a piece of information and you get 50
people saying although we know the truth
if the council then seeks to immediately
post something to Sabol actually that's
not true you know you'll get 50 people
saying well they would say that wouldn't
they so I think you know it has to be a
little bit more of a measured
Chester how we we tackle lose those
sorts of issues and it's just the way
that some of these things can go viral
just wonder if there's any way we could
control at all I mean we're quite
proactive with you know when things like
that happen certainly if there are you
know figures that are incorrect we will
try and respond with a press release
putting the correct information out
there and we have also previously used
to frequently asked questions and if we
see something like that we can then
refer people to the council website
where the f IQs are because that thing
stops us getting involved in a
conversation with quite frankly
sometimes we just cannot win but you
know we work on all the facts that the
facts are on the website and this is the
this is the money if you've got any
other queries then obviously usually
there's a information or contact at the
bottom there but that's how we try and
deal with that kind of situation I know
it's not always you you're always going
to get to a point in social media but
the best way I think to go against that
is to put the facts out there and make
sure that people know how to find them
Lucas gills raised with responses to
third-party social media messages is
that something that would be included
within a social media policy social
media policy so my question would be
firstly I assume that's been actively
worked on I mean have you got a date
that that will be coming forward and
secondly how does that affect social
media use now prior to us actually even
having a policy in place I think there's
at this difference between how the
council response to social media and how
perhaps
two members might respond because
individual members could respond to
anything they wanted on social media and
in some respects that might be the
appropriate way to actually deal with
particular issues but I mean I think the
council as a corporate body has got to
take a measured approach to how we might
deal with the you know third party posts
on social media not least because if we
started to post in a corporate council
responses to individual queries will be
will spend all the time doing nothing
but blogging and so that's why the
approach that Vanessa's I don't mind is
really the favorite for us to put an
information sign post information etc
through the website and so in terms of
the social media policy I'm sure we've
got a date for finalizing it as yet how
does that leave us at the moment if we
do not have a social policy in place or
agreed but we are using social media to
counsel are we exposed anyway or are we
I mean I think I think the social media
chairman of things social media pub I
mean I think it just adds to the
existing safeguards that we have through
the normal employment contract
arrangements and the policies and
procedures that my staff had to have to
comply with so I think it's seeking to
add and and help you know develop that a
little bit but I don't think it
necessarily provides any more safeguards
already exist pretty firm in terms of
handles those matters to deal with
already thank you thank you for your
list of social problems quite
interesting I've been involved with the
Youth Council and their preferred
platform is snapchat and that is the one
that they are planning to use to promote
the council the Youth Council as you the
comment that they passed when I
suggested putting out a Facebook page
for the Youth Council sets for old
people and I think it's one of the
things that we need to probably be aware
because I'm no IT slouch but I was quite
surprised at their reaction when I
suggested some of the sites that you say
that the council are using at the moment
and perhaps it would be an idea if we've
got targeted media issues that we're
really looking to do which are youth
orientated that we actually primarily
look at snapchat because apparently that
is the medium that all the teenagers use
at the moment not even Instagram
I think snapchat uses a lot of video as
well and that is definitely an avenue
that we are looking to explore more now
we've got the senior comms officer back
from maternity leave hopefully we will
be able to have some time to look into
that type thing but I believe snapchat
is used for visual and isn't it
photographs and videos so for something
linking with a Youth Council there and
share some information but I mean that's
that's handy to know because there are a
big audience that we need to try
they meet tonight canceler mr. Boyd
Thank You gemenon probably just repeat
but a big problem every makes me about
social media policy I've mentioned
snapchat you shouldn't just be the youth
Castle should be announcing it is the
medium of younger people with teenagers
ending to twenties and even 50 year olds
use it if I'm Phillip Schofield users it
is not amusing
there's no I can't see what they
originally showed about the council
using snapchat it's quite easy to use
your post pictures I think snapchat
would be ideal for the event under
snapchat film to around an area you want
to help me why would I why would they
call it aside
well yesterday snapchat filters around
the area it's absolutely brilliant for
that and attracting people you're
certainly getting the different
audiences counselor you said young
people do not they might be on Facebook
but they don't care they may be on
tweeter but they don't matter you use
Twitter they'll be on Instagram it leads
me to another question Instagram what's
the name of the account on Instagram
because I haven't found brought to
District Council on fine Rockford Youth
Council which has 103 Jake followers
snowshoed isn't that one open if you
find the district councils a separate
one because I just think it's important
the the Youth Council crowded separately
to the district council I might always
watch for DC every week we can circulate
that to all things you know yeah I'm
sure it's a swatch with deceive you as
our Twitter dance I think there's this
blockage with big development snapchat
not really understanding how it Jews
these it really is used with photographs
and videos yes but it's not it doesn't
have to be a selfie it could be a
picture it it could have been a feature
of the Tommies of a nickel girl snapchat
and it's not a problem
I don't nothing that's really important
where we should be moving towards as
well otherwise we're missing a massive
proportion of the population we don't
cancel Griffin Thank You charlie this
daily monitoring that we can some public
colleges or is it just like from my end
of office hours on a Friday through the
following Monday we don't we do have a
payment message on on our social
accounts to say that it isn't it isn't
monitored but depending on what's going
on for example if we have travelers in
the district obviously it becomes used
by our emergency team and the
communications team as well sometimes
when I'm at home something will pop up
and if it does need to be dealt with
immediately
if it's urgent then I'm doing that
typically we don't right thank you thank
you very much just really for the
purposes I've just had a look it is
Rockford DC or the Instagram which I've
now just followed it speaking about
everybody to be me okay thank you very
much
any further questions yes I think if
you're happy to in an agreement maybe
this is something we could revisit in
perhaps twelve months time even if it's
just an update really to the week and
use the figures that have been given
tonight just to see how it's moving how
it's progressing
I'll be doing brace the knee it moves so
quickly in 12 months something could be
something completely different so if
you're happy with that look Jimmy I mean
I think it'd be happy to provide some
stats from time to time through members
bulletins okay okay members agreed okay
thank you come and see me emotive over
to stay
[Music]
okay moving on 2007 is the removal of
the payment kiosks for this item
we welcome rapidly financing cancers
this purpose is reported to update
members on what's happened since the
removal of the payment kiosks has been
circulated its expansion absolutely
thank you check so so really just to
just to kind of pull out a few key bits
of shipping as the reports lacing to
correct one the machines were brought in
back in 2011 so as you can imagine they
they were getting beyond their their
useful life and so a decision had to be
made your on this year whether we invest
in them or whether we look to remove
them the operational decision from the
leadership team was that we removed them
some of the key key points are there in
paragraph three as to why we did that
the main one being that we would have
had to upgrade the machines cost of five
thousand-pound but also with GDP our
regulations coming in at the end of May
the machines weren't going to be
satisfactorily compliant under those
regulations just if I could carry over
to paragraph six and just kind of size
some of those additional costs as well
great the machine but save the savings
that we've been able to achieve from
from removing them total just under 19
thousand pound including some officer
support time in by the reception in
helping people use the machines but also
some cash office back office time in
processing the last amount of cash that
we were getting through through machines
at the time and since they remove them
the machines if I can take you over to
some of the tables on page seven point
three so paragraph eight I'm pleased to
say that particularly with council tax I
place an emphasis on council tax within
the report because majority of cash
being paid through the to kiosk was for
council tax and to a lesser extent
business rates I'm pleased to say as as
the table shows the council tax
collection rates are where we would have
expected them to be at the end of
September there was a slight drop in May
and then again through July it was to
summer months but that's not uncommon
through summer months but in September
it's come back to where it should be the
other encouraging point is and a stress
that this was through the good
communication and marketing that was
done through Nelson tax department
themselves it was the uptake in Direct
Debit we see from the table in 8.3 we've
jumped that doesn't seem a lot but we've
jumped from a just over eighty three
percent just over 80 books it's
basically a percentage increase in those
paying their council tax by direct debit
which is really encouraging because
we've been clattering around 83% for
quite a while
so obviously that has impacted from
removing those machines we've just in
addition to the report we did look at
the option and I had some members come
to me and
members of the finance team around could
we offer payment services through like a
post office in Rochford given that there
were no banks in botsford we did look at
that unfortunately the process would
have been that we would have had to add
a bar code to our council tax bills and
the cost of doing that plus implementing
the software and enhancements to the
academy council tax system would have
been a one-off cost of seven just under
eighteen thousand pounds seventeen
thousand eight hundred and twenty pound
and then an ongoing annual charge of one
thousand nine hundred and eighty pound
given that the high we've given that we
didn't have a high level of complaints
we had nine official complaints come
through the department all of which say
all seven of which we managed to get
people into other payment methods to
we're still accepting cash because of
mitigating circumstances with those two
people given those low numbers we
decided not to go ahead with the bar
coding on billing but it's something
that is an option there if we ever
choose to and the figures potentially if
they did drop there's still not risk the
potential things could drop off but as I
say from the figures we're seeing so far
from the six months from implementation
it's looking healthy and it was it's
deemed to be a good decision I'm happy
to take any questions thank you very
much
out there's nine to seven and complaint
or any of those directly with regards to
may have been facilities and in
Waterford they were all in with regards
to people wanting to pay cash into a
kiosk so they were kiosk paying kiosk
using people we spoke to them all
individually and managed to get them to
find otherwise far too
and also I think it's handier but you
mentioned about the earthly uptake of
the directivity Sam and I have played
you know there is the uptake was zero
couldn't think 9% no I think when you
look at that and written down it to me
that didn't actually look a successful
increase and I was I was thinking that
was a result the market did not be in
that effective but you have talked on
that this evening and you're quite happy
about that
yeah I mean when you when you consider
that we're collecting in the region of
45 million pound a year of cabinet
actually all Rockford's money but we're
collecting them in about a year one
percent increase is substantial when
you're talking that sum of money
thank you very much councillor Stanley
Thank You chairman just to sort of
balance this up a little bit with type
17.3 can you elaborate why the figures
of very much the same as 2017-18 as
ain't a 19 what happened to the other
percentage so so that's sorry it's only
the other question though you just made
that question so we're into a particular
row award and what in toppika from April
to September they're very much to sign
figures which I would have stopped was
but things to be a little bit oh really
because I'm surprised that they would be
this up almost the same figures so I
think that's what the table was to show
that actually yeah it should have some
sort of effect very little in effect
that's all
there's been an increase there's been an
increase we cancel tax in any case so
that would actually show somewhat of a
horror figure I would thought and what
it is already so it's usually displaying
what is and whether or not you would
have expected a lot yes so basically
that what the take all seeking to show
this table is purely about council tax
collections so as at the end of
September 2017 18 we collected twenty
eight and a half million pounds was at
the end of September this financial year
30 million three hundred fifty eight
thousand that is exactly on track where
we would expect to have collected that
amount of council tax at that stage so
what what the table seeking to share is
that council council tax collection has
not decreased from removing the company
pending heels yes they were exactly
where we expected it to be I expected it
be somewhat a little bit higher or even
or even lower than because of the kiosk
is not there now any longer often you
mentioned it to be low of might surprise
that you know obviously a lot of people
going direct debits so so this I think I
think what you're getting confused that
is this this is a table to show what we
should be collecting in council tax not
just through the chaos but why by any
means of payment this is what we should
be collecting on council tax right what
the table is showing is that those
statistics have not dropped in any way
so what when when we had the kiosks X
amount of that thirty million was being
paid in cash poor check through the
payment console in the in reception
those consoles were taken away but
there's been no drop in that income of
council tax those people have found
alternative methods of payment which
we've marketed with them which we've
spoken to them about so there's no
there's no drop we are still on target
to collect ninety eight point three
percent of council tax
is what we set out to achieve at the
beginning of the year okay thank you
thank you for curing that cancer AIDS
thank you Kevin just one question on the
nine complaints that you heard you said
there are two that you've got acceptable
circumstances - and you made
arrangements with them to be able to pay
in cash yes how is that working
what's the arrangement so those though
my understanding is those I know at
least one of the two definitely we have
a visiting officer due to the mitigating
circumstances that individual was
already going to detail visiting officer
goes out and collects the cash issues a
receipt and we bank that cash through
the Lloyds branch I think that Thank You
chairman it seemed from your previous
answer that council still has the
ability to receive payments other than
by card and direct debit is actually
making a policy decision to attempt to
make those alternative forms of payment
not advertised or not generally
available to everyone is that correct so
yes we we still collect cash but we only
collect cash in mitigating circumstances
or for example if I have my council tax
enforcement officer and a court hearing
and somebody is about to be thrown into
prison if they don't pay their council
tax and all they have is cash then we
will take cash
understand that checks are also accepted
as well correct forward council services
we're still collecting checks at the
moment however we are writing to every
resident and service user who is paying
by cash so pay by cheque to notify them
the eventually council will look to
phase out the acceptance of checks we
haven't yet set a time line in the sand
for that but that's an operational
decision that we want to carry forward
in the near future in relation to
council tax at the beginning of the
financial year when everyone receives
their council tax bill on those on those
bills they are gives out information
about payment considering that so this
is one of the only communicate forms of
communication that goes for everyone's
door from the council that and and the
there was a change in circumstances and
the type of service ability to make
payments was what wasn't there a general
communication with all council tax
payers about the change of circumstance
at the time and the cost of writing to
32 circuited 32,000 households would
have fallen out our wake the savings
that we're currently making see the
majority of council taxpayers have
already got in place that their payment
their methods of payment so we targeted
those that were paying by cash a flyer
was produced communication was made with
those individuals
going forward into next year's billing
process the back of the bill won't give
that option of paying by cat
and possibly used in the social media
only because some other members of India
you've stated about communication with
relation to individuals I've had the
opportunity to listen to some of the
communication from some of the staff in
the revenues and benefits I'll describe
it as intimidation and bullying
naturally to try to force people to a
particular payment system that they do
not wish to do I don't I think probably
the Smith wants to see something's over
I know I really take that that
navigation extremely seriously and I'm
extremely upset it's actually being made
in the in the committee that evening so
I just want to put on record you know
that would mark my my concern about that
about that comment very firmly fees of
the requests that the officer does not
answer that question I think is wholly
inappropriate statement and they've been
made it's an issue that I think there
are mechanisms if the if there's a
natural issue to be raised here you
might need to say that I've witnessed it
so I'm stating as I see so I don't think
that individual members of the revenues
and benefit staff would have done this
off of their own back this would have
been
this is not an appropriate place for a
statement like this there are quite
clear mechanisms of which complaints can
be made about the way in which the
council operates that's the route that
needs to be taken thank you so so pay
point is is the post office facility
that I spoke oh no I mean I think point
is the one we've got this so that's why
we would leave with our coding the bar
code on the physical council tax bill
for that to happen
so it's an option then we can continue
to look at this point is do you charge
and they claim they it's not it could be
100 reasons why likely gay they could
pay no so the process for if we're just
talking about council tax yeah the
process would be that they would go
through our enforcement cos tax
enforcement office so a reminder would
be sent out if that was still ignored
then that would be taken through
judicial process now I'm just saying it
was June 1st they did pay to the table
would they still incur a late payment
there's there's no late payment charge
but they would be chased as to why they
haven't paid
the day they're due to pay is that an
automated system I assume yes absolutely
okay counselor mr. Boyd thank you
chilly discussing zone off quite
skeptical I have to admit when this I
first learnt of this and it appears that
perhaps it's not quite as address on
something because I may have thought so
congratulations to the team from
obviously helping people to pay because
most people do want to pay but obviously
change is very difficult for many people
and hopefully it will continue that they
can still manage to pay and I show this
be monitored throughout the year to make
sure that that will happen with gone -
I've come to the door the direct debits
I'm not containing about dardanius check
there's quite a minor point your app
your app - a collection of eighty four
point one five percent in July which is
four and twenty four point oh four in
September is that a normal trend I don't
know I would have to look right I just
wonder if it wasn't yet the burst and
then people are fighting because I would
understand that if some people who set
up direct debits who who hadn't
previously if a direct debit fails I
believe you have to research it up
correct so I'm wondering if that might
be an issue where people have been
zapped on direct debits and perhaps
they're stopped there's a circumstances
of Laura deputies they're not used to be
starting to fail well I have a look at
the trend
nothing could be worked and see if any
are enemies fighting while for the good
people moving attraction could happen as
well just on sorry the last point I
don't want to interrupt you now the only
one the last part was quite nor do you
mean when he's not really on this beauty
bringing up is about phasing out checks
will there be a consultation on the
phasing out of checks but
I have that into I'm leaving the effect
at Christmas yes the section 151 office
will lead on that process and I will
liaise with and get her to advise you on
what that process I think dad's law is
very quite quite well the anticipation
of what this might have been did bring
the long belters on people but the
reality of the fact is that the impact
has been very very small people don't
like change and it's the sort of change
that causes concern and with hearsay and
anecdotal evidence things can get blown
out of proportion but the reality is
this process of change was something
that showed the strength and the skill
of many of our staff in helping
individuals and we also have to think
about the part we have to play in though
in the modern world the fact is the way
money is handled is changing people do
have to get used to the fact that cash
is becoming outdated at all it will
always be around but encouraging people
to carry large amounts of cash from one
place to another to pay it through a
little machine that's not a good idea to
to encourage people to come to terms
with modern electronic methods of
pavement is I think part of a wider
council duty so I think there's been
that there's been a number of positives
for us through this project I mean
clearly there's a financial element we
can't deny that there is some some
savings we've ended up being much more
secure with the way we hand on people's
data and that's not to be taken lightly
we've not seen any financial impact in
terms of collection rates and we've done
this bit of taking society forward with
with the way it handles cash and
although I mean we talk about checks not
being taken at some stage in the future
remember that in society there's an
awful lot of places that don't take
checks already we're actually a little
bit behind the curve with that one
so yes at some stage as an operational
issue officers will look at how to face
those checks out I think there's been a
major point about px which which some
members may be aware of and I know that
number of local authorities have already
across the country have refused to stop
taking checks and the reason that they
generally give for doing that is the
checks are not legal tender you know
it's just a promissory note and
therefore you know they've used that
argument as as being key to counsel sure
I said every member thought well which
was asked to do regarding from this
review committee and some of the points
that advice tonight are actually in
there regarding the PI point why
couldn't go in etc so it would have been
helpful with members that actually read
this retained it to my songs but wasting
some of our officers time thank you
going back to PI point and in relation
to fact that decided that you very cost
in cosmetic he was deciding not to
pursue it although you have stated that
there is the possibility that the
council could look at this in the future
the fact that how would you be able to
monetary because if you set it up and it
was operating and it wasn't used very
much you could have an argument to say
well actually
there's a reason for not continuing it
but we did not be in there you wouldn't
be able to make no proper assessment as
to its popularity you might find that if
you set it up and it was a service that
was available that it might actually be
something that people might prefer to
use but with the way that things are
currently there's no way or means to
make a proper assessment of that so I
would suggest that that is set up and so
that we can see that how popular that
this might be yeah I mean I think we've
just heard for the last 27 minutes how
successful the system has been why are
we trying to confuse and complicate the
system even more most people have taken
as far as I can hear have taken this new
system that was fought in have embraced
it we've had the same number of people
or a bigger increase in people taking it
up as far as I'm aware apart from two
that's been highlighted everybody else
has managed to succeed in making their
payments so why are we now starting to
bring in other issues and other modes of
payment when when it's all working I
can't quite understand the logic in in
this argument that's all because the end
of the council was meant to be there as
in that businessman up there only show
Nicholas calm helped to create
and says that the resident is the center
of that the vendor is losing the
residents have embraced it they just
prove that because they've all taken it
well that's not the information that
I've received we've been told there's
two people who are given special
arrangements because to pay cash
everybody else is on board and I've had
over a dozen people in my ward complain
to me directly about this and these
other complaints and these other other
issues of people complain about you know
they might not necessarily go down there
visual group okay can I then recommend
if your residents complain about that
specific issue they make contact
accounts cuz I'm assuming that would be
a good guide as to whether a certain
facility was needed or not if the food
that doesn't get positive to the council
they can't do that so I think it's
probably wise to ask them to give the
council's about the council connected
necessary the other one other aspects
about this I'll be very brief is that
council tax mm-hmm as a service is not
something that someone can go somewhere
else for so if you are looking to
purchase or fire services from normal
things you might choose to go to a term
eternity way if that particular service
provider doesn't mean there isn't that
facility with council tax you have to
pay the council that you're in you can't
find you know if they then respect your
means of payment by it by its own their
only safety in certain way there's no
alternative you have to follow that they
saw a chairman but we just you've just
had this answered once if you if you
leave your residents have a complaint or
an issue please contact the council the
rest everybody else seems to embrace the
situation you've got your people take
that
counselor perfectly okay counselor mr.
hoi didn't choose my words carefully and
I believe it would be miss be remiss of
any counselor sitting around this table
at this point in time not to question
officers about any aspect of this report
regardless of whether another member of
Senate report around about it including
the fact I think the other maybe we
should remember that some members who
asked about pain point or not actually
members of this committee and therefore
may not have received that at all they
are substitutes I think to just
sweepingly state that we always the
officers time by asking questions about
pain point is wrong and I do not accept
it I will leave you there actually all
members not just members of this
committee it went out if remember of
counsel other members come back teeth
were not one review but just one point I
deal with a lot with the homeless if
someone who lived sleeps in a field can
get a basic account bank account someone
even in that house can also get a basic
bank account so that's why we can use
stand in order Direct Debit so it might
be safe someone can live in the field or
in a street dog and got a bank account
everyone else did it in the house who
pays council tax got a bank account I
know it was mentioned about domestic
abuse victims I spoke to the people in
changing pathways they have the means to
set up an account for any woman or man
that is thread the home to set up a bank
account that can actually get their
money into so if there are ways and
means are doing this thank you thank you
now I've made up specific statement
chairman around the fact that it's our
right to question offices and we should
not be poor from questioning officers by
other statements when you see Thursday
when it is on record so well now no more
question in each other
about that if anyone has any other
questions or any other points that would
like to make pleasing goodnight if not
then I'll ask members to refer to the
recommendation which is to know the
contents of a question I will see the
conversation went in a different
direction
I didn't hear directly from the officer
s - in relation to how how the option of
pay point would be assessed you know
going into the future we didn't actually
get response from the officer so I think
my response my response would be I
already said through the report is that
given the collection rates specifically
for council taxes as this that facility
would be useful collection rates are
where they should be
we're on targets who collect ninety
eight point two percent of our council
tax from residents which is where it
should be
I don't see a need as head of wires I
don't see a need to bring in another
facility in the moment having said that
if collection rates deep trough and and
it was due to due to any circulation
rates they've got dropping for them we
would yes sister presumably thank you
are we happy to note the contents of
that report
okay members moving on to item 8 which
is Ripa for existing members you know
this is something that we hear the new
members just to let you know this is
some community of year seldom user which
is reflected in the report this report
seems more to focus on in particular
covert human intelligence sources ever
taken part in this and social media
members of other shops I believe it I
can refer you to Louise the most
assistant director or preteen housing
who attends this evening for this item
if you could just briefly summarize it
follow any points that you wanted to do
all right to it thank you I think you've
probably already covered it as I say our
activity using our River powers is very
consistent as in we haven't used it over
the last year and you know members are
being asked and recommended to approve
the changes to the river policy which
essentially the changes are staffing
changes around responsibilities around
their covert sources and clarifying that
in the policy to make it clearer based
on a recommendation from the
commissioner's office the most
importantly it's been added to to give
extra guidance to officers around the
use of social media media and it's
linked to the river policy so I really
you know are hopefully it's
self-explanatory I'm very happy to take
any further questions
Paul would be happy to support me as
well if there's any detail just also to
let you know the social media policy
wasn't something we just licked up out
of thin air we're very openly said we
can plagiarize but we asked Colchester
about their policy which has already
been endorsed by the Commissioner's
Office and they very kindly said that we
could use simple so we love to do it we
have consulted with staff and all the
Ripper and authorised officers have had
a look at it as well so just to give you
some certainty it isn't something we've
just done and just said here it is
officers having dooster as well I
understand it many members funny
question is can stick with me did you
want to play something another cream on
you interests had a bit that it was just
about modern methods of recording
information we have them it can be
almost inadvertent where you have like a
dash cam or a helmet camera on a bike
that sort of thing does that come into
the River area at all no not even an old
person is providing us information at
all it's it's quite clear on that
actually the if you've got CCTV as long
as you've got signs up saying the CCTV
is in use in that area you're covered is
nothing however it differs somewhat if
you could manipulate the cameras and
follow someone so you see when I'm at
the high street and you actually could
follow that person of the high street
with that camera and you just kick right
you're watching them and yes it starts
to fall under that right people for us
we haven't got any of that
Thank You counselor eat thank you
just a good one excuse my naivety
obviously it's the first time I've
actually been involved with this 28
Christi only specific training that's
given to officers with regards to this
as detailed in the report members and
officers which received training in
March in July what's that training it's
just an overview of the riddler powers
and also it concentrated a little bit on
the social media aspect delivery-boy an
external specialist
thank you thank you cancers family Thank
You chairman um just a little thing that
I thought I people come in or not but if
we are would we sorry I'll be phrasing
would we if we are asked to do
surveillance for some one reason or
another from another Authority all we
say that we wouldn't do that now we
wouldn't do it we had to do any kind of
covert surveillance we would have to go
to the you know the courts to ask for
that we wouldn't do anything we were
doing on those devices from another
capsule it does thank you Jim
there's counsel would have directly your
honor is controlling CCTV cameras or
systems actively monitors
any other questions or points anybody
wants to raise if not then there are two
recommendations we'll take them
separately the first is for counsel to
recommend the amendments to the
council's written policy set out in
section 4 above that they're approved or
is it agreement very early and the
second is that the new policy relating
to the use of social media in relation
to investigations which is attached in
appendix to the reports themselves right
sorry I'm going to cut back to the
recommendations I'm sorry about this
right as a committee you can only know
the council's and usage ripper all right
that's your duty the second the other
two you've got to recommend to council
okay now I just needs you to say you
agree with those records are you here
for the record did you put
recommendation 10.1 is for members to
note you're growing and recommendations
1 & 2 which I made in 10.2
so much
okay okay right is ugly two items on P
decision document last month there were
three there was one about beauty Garden
villages which has since been removed
and I'll tell you why it was the voice
that local authorities have established
that is too early in the process to
engage in this government initiative it
might be that obviously alongside
partners engage at a later date only the
best no indication is to win no they
just did the partners are Essex County
South End and ourselves and basically
they're just too early
Paul was I think to the projection of a
similar plan in North Essex I have no
idea I have okay only have the
information passed on
they just decided it was too early okay
so going back to the other two that are
on there item 318 the a one two seven
air quality project you will notice the
date for that is November I'm told it
might slip into and then the other ones
he advice services contracted so if it
slips beyond mouch does that mean they
don't know what they need to comply with
it I'm told the air quality one slip he
will come out away before Christmas
because it's got to be there by the 31st
of December
I spoke to Martin today and he assured
me I don't know the early December and
we state that cuz it sister she
retrieved compliance with EU air quality
targets yeah yeah I'm um I think the
date is aiming for for the report we go
out beautiful
yes sorry yes I mean thanks very much
Paul for the information there through
some first rights cuz I thought I
thought something was missing from the K
decision document I'm not noticed in the
past that key decisions done almost
become decisions would it be possible or
would the committee agree that perhaps
in key decisions disappeared from a
document we can just have a note often
wrong read on poultry remember an orchid
and then we had edgy form you have a
know that P decisions of obviously we
know which key decisions become
decisions because we see them but K
decisions we've stone it become a
decision that just stop being this
decision I think the number there just
put a hose under the impression that the
air quality measurement had been set and
I passed a test well this is wrong
I believe counselor Webb mentioned it at
a meeting I think this is the indication
we need to wait for the official which
is taken to confirm what indications are
indicating better phrase I think yeah I
did have a very technical explanation
for Martin I don't it you want to try
retain I'm bound to get it right okay
members odd number temperatures work
plan notice we've got a pump the
treasury management mid-year review
that's last time the committee's leaving
the operation of the development
committee that will be Marcus as he's
now taken over the planning and the
report from the working group they've
been looking you know a review committee
that in looking at the de Montfort
University report yes
I presume that nothing formerly only
knows I spoke to police things certainly
news for series know it's coming I don't
a bee has been the official statement
that I think he's common knowledge
yeah I think probably because he's in
the handover stage of matter because we
still got Matthew but Matthew goes
[Music]